kourosh chamlou bonjour merci d'être
avec nous dans la matinale de rtl france
alors pour commencer peut-être un
éclairage un l'iran appelle donc on le
disait joe biden a levé les sanctions
touchant les médicaments contre le colis
19 pourtant ces sanctions contre l'iran
est l'exemple officiellement les denrées
alimentaires les médicaments et d'autres
produits de première nécessité alors
pourquoi dans les faits ce n'est pas le
cas bonjour merci de m'avoir invité
oui dans les faits c'est ce n'est pas le
cas puisque les sanctions ne nous
concerne pas l'alimentation
l'agriculture et aussi bien les produits
pharmaceutiques
mais dans les faits les iraniens ne
peuvent transiger avec aucune banque ne
peuvent envoyer ni recevoir de l'argent
donc les banques internationales refuse
de faire affaires avec l'iran parce
qu'ils ont peur des sanctions
américaines
et dans ce cas là les iraniens dans les
faits ne peuvent pas importer des
produits pharmaceutiques et notamment
les produits pour pouvoir lutter contre
de vaccins sinon ces sanctions ne
concerne pas les produits
pharmaceutiques alors l'iran kiki ceux
qui souhaitent un désormais se tourner
vers des laboratoires occidentaux pour
acheter des médicaments
pourtant le guide suprême iranien ali
khamenei avait interdit l'importation de
vaccins contre la colite 19 fabriquées
aux états unis et au royaume uni alors
comment comprendre ce changement en
finale 24 passes et la situation est
presque catastrophique en iran il y a
vous savez en iran juge je suis rentré
hier matin avant-hier matin virant les
restaurants les tout est ouvert
les gens se baladent dans les rues et il
ya de plus en plus de 99 même si le
gouvernement ne le dit pas le guide
suprême à plusieurs reprises à
intervilles les vaccins américains et
anglais mais il n'a pas interdit les
vaccins russe les iraniens sont en même
temps en train de développer leur propre
vaccin avec les des cubains mais quand
est-ce que ce vaccin va être prêt on le
sait pas et les iraniens ont besoin de
vaccin et la population demandent à et
taxis menée le plus rapidement possible
c'est pour ça que le ministre des
affaires étrangères
arif est parti en russie et a signé un
accord pour pouvoir acheter le vaccin
soutenu mais comme la politique
étrangère est définie par le guide
suprême
il a interdit le vaccin les vaccins
américains et anglais
ils pourront pas apporter ses l'accent
là même si l'iran souhaite acheter un
vaccin qui est suède aubry tanner bon le
fait qu'ils soient sauvés des eaux
britanniques ça change quelque chose
ça change pas ça change pas grand chose
sauf que dans la situation dans cette
situation de crise sanitaire
ils vont ils vont s'accommoder avec ça
et ils vont ils vont y vont l'emporter
ils vont dire que ce n'est pas le
britannique mais ces suédois là en iran
le gouvernement sait bien jouer avec les
mots pour pouvoir imposer son point de
vue
alors vous revenez d'iran vous ne disiez
quelle est la situation sur place
notamment on pense aux hôpitaux est ce
qu'il ya des manques de moyens à ce que
les hôpitaux sont saturés comment est-ce
que ça se passe alors on ne sait pas
vraiment si les hôpitaux sont saturés ou
pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
hôpitaux manquent de moyens les
pharmacies manque de médicaments vous
savez la crise et économique est grave
les prix augmentent tous les jours quand
je vous dis tous les jours c'est
pratiquement tous les jours le prix de
l'immobilier le prix de location de pour
louer un appartement
les prix de l'automobile le dollar et
les cris de devises augmentent chaque
jour et l'iran enfin les hôpitaux ne
trouve aucun médicament il n'ya il n'y a
pratiquement pas de médicaments
étrangers sur le marché iranien
les pharmacies sont obligés d'acheter
des médicaments il en est qui sont pas
très très performant
donc on est on est obligé de pouvoir
signer des accords avec l'étranger et
dans ce cas là il faudrait que les
américains les blés sanctions bancaires
au mois pour que l'iran puisse acheter
des médicaments salutaire pour que
l'iran puisse envoyer de l'argent aux
banques étrangères pour pouvoir recevoir
ces médicaments si les sanctions
bancaires ne sont pas levés l'iran
pourra à acquérir ces médicaments et est
ce qu'avec la nouvelle administration de
joe biden la population iranienne croit
à la levée de ces sanctions en tout cas
en partie oui
la population croit à la levée des
sanctions puisque comme vous savez joe
biden était vice-présidente pensée
d'accord a été signé tony blinken qui
est actuellement le sécrétaire d'état
dont le ministre des affaires étrangères
aux états unis était un des négociateurs
de cet apport pour la levée des
sanctions et la population il croît
fortement puisqu'ils pensent que la
situation va revenir avant la situation
de 2016 c'est à dire une levée des
sanctions contre l'arrêt de
l'enrichissement d'uranium à part les
iraniens quand est-ce que ça va arriver
on sait pas vous savez dans six mois on
a des élections présidentielles
iraniennes
on sait pas qui va être élu mais si
c'est la droite conservatrice ou même si
c'est à peu près j'avais les libéraux la
politique étrangère est définie par le
guide suprême et le guide suprême a dit
à plusieurs reprises qu'il faut que
l'iran pas que l'iran rende dans
l'accord mais que les américains
puissent rentrer dans l'accord pour que
la ctu de la situation économique
s'améliore alors justement la russie a
avec l'iran ont effectivement souligné
ce besoin urgent de restaurer l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien c'est quelque
chose qui doit aller vite aujourd'hui ça
doit aller ça doit aller très très vite
puis ce que je dis les prix augmentent
chaque jour environ l'iran l'iran a
réussi à exporter un peu de pétrole mais
pas énormément de l'acier de la
situation économique est catastrophique
si les américains ne les fans les
sanctions le plus rapidement possible
les iraniens vont continuer à enrichir
l'uranium
et si vous n'arrivez pas à arrêter les
iraniens maintenant ou dans cinq ou six
mois ils vont enrichir l'uranium de plus
en plus est la seule façon d'arrêter
dans ce cas là le programme iranien
le programme nucléaire iranien c'est par
une guerre s'il ya juste de voir pour
arrêter ce programme soit la négociation
soit la guerre civile si vous ne votez
pas aussi vous ne réussissez pas à
négocier avec les iraniens
les américains ne réussissent pas à
revenir sur la table de négociations il
va falloir faire la guerre pour pouvoir
arrêter le programme nucléaire
sinon l'iran va acquérir
la bombe nucléaire merci beaucoup
kourosh chamlou d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin en direct sur ft franche de rappel
vous êtes avocat franco iranien